مستمره واخره بالاتساع تلك الازمه التي
هزت منصه تويتر منذ استحوذ عليها اواخر
اكتوبر الماضي الملياردير الامريكي ايلون
ماسك مقابل 44 مليار دولار
فخلال نحو شهر واحد من ملكيته لها واجهت
شبكه الرائده مشكلات ومازقه لم تشهدها منذ
انشائها لقد بات مصير الموقع من الاساس
موضع نقاش وتكهنات اولى قرارات ماس كانت
تسريحه نصف عدد الموظفين بمنفيهم مدير
سياسات وكبار مسؤولي الرقابه والاداره
المخضرمين قبل ان يلحق بهم مزيدا من
زملائهم في موجه استقالات واسعه بسبب
انعدام الامان الوظيفي وسرعان ما حلت
العواقب وخيمه اذ المت الثغرات ولا اعطاب
الفنيه بتويتر بينها توقف عمل النظام
الالي لحقوق الملكيه الفكريه على المنصه
كما تم الابلاغ عن مواجهه مشتركين مصاعب
في تحميل بياناتهم بينما اشتكى اخرون من
قرصنه حساباتهم ومن بطء استعادتها حيث
استغرق الامر اياما في بعض الاحيان
وكان من نتائج تلك الفوضى ان تراجع مستوى
الامان والثقه في تويتر حيث اوقف معلنون
اشتراكاتهم فيه اثر مغادره مسؤوليتي تسويق
كبار المنصه الشهيره كما يثير نظام
التوثيق الجديد الذي يرغب ماسك في تطبيقه
قدرا كبيرا من الارباك وسوء الفهم لا سيما
معتزام الرجل الاثر في العالم فرض رسم
شهري مقداره ثمانيه دولارات لعلامه
التوثيق الزرقاء
حتى الان لا يبدي مالك تويتر الجديد اي
استعداد للتراجع عن خطواته التي يصفها
كثيرون بالمتهوره بل هو من فك يهاجم يوميا
تلك الانتقادات عبر حسابه مستخدما اسلوب
السخريه والاستفزاز اكثر من ذلك يؤكد ماسك
ان استخدامات تويتر زاد في عهده متعهدا
بطرح منتجات جديده على المنصه ومن الخطوات
المثيره للجدل قراره الاسبوع الماضي تفعيل
الحسابات المحظوره بما فيها حساب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
متراجعا عن وعوده السابقه بان لا يفعل ذلك
مطلقا
تدابير بررها ماسك بانها استندت الى
استفتاء واسع شارك فيه ملايين المشتركين
لكنها لا تقنع منتقديه الذين يتوقعون
الاسوء لمنصه تويتر قائلين
انون ماسك هو الازمه بحد ذاتها